Joe's with us in Atlanta so what's your
net worth Joe about six cool what's that
invested in couple houses some stocks uh
mutual funds and some CDs okay and
what's most of it in I'd say most of its
in mutual funds gotcha
cool and what's been the range of your
income through your working life sir
household income Oh probably if you had
the average would be eighty to a hundred
thousand okay well you guys make these
days we're both retired now okay what's
your age I'm 68 okay cool how much of
the six million did you inherit about
two hundred thousand and when did you
get that when I was oh this has to be
fifteen years ago okay so how much of
that six million do you think that is
due to you having gotten that 200k Oh
probably four hundred yeah okay all
right that's cool and what was your
career when your working life time sir I
work in a recording studio okay and um
what's your degree in I have no degree
okay cool was your high school GPA oh
three five okay cool and how much of the
six million is due to borrowing money to
make money
none okay all right so how did you get
six million dollars at sixty eight years
old were to come from um my wife and I
both worked and we lived off of my
paycheck Wow and so she threw her what
would what did she do for a living she
worked for the state okay through her
entire paycheck into the end of
investments in yes Wow that's
substantial that's very cool
and so you didn't just live below your
means you live substantially below your
means absolutely okay cool so what part
did giving play on these financial
decisions over the years even though we
are not part of organized religion we
give away ten percent of our income okay
all right
to nonprofits and so forth huh yeah okay
cool so what's the most expensive pair
of jeans you ever bought well you really
have to ask my wife but I would think
twenty-five dollars or so okay all right
cool and how many new cars did you buy
before you had a million dollars before
I had a million none okay cool so what
would your advice be to the 25 year old
version of you out there listening live
way below your means okay don't don't
that is terrible I agree with you
we have no debt we have had debt in
years we just we don't like that we pay
our credit card bills off every month we
don't borrow money we had a we had a
little bit of debt when we bought our
second home and we had a 5/1 arm and we
paid it off in four years
okay so just you hate debt and live on
less than you make and be in it be a
heavy investor yep that was what you did
it really wasn't anything any sexier
than that then that's right
congratulations sir it's an honor to
talk to you you're great hero six
million dollar net worth starting from
nothing okay so five point five million
one point seven five one point five 1
million one point four million is 6
million was who I talked to in the last
hour
none of them inherited the money none of
them were crooks none of them were
athletes and I think only one of them's
wife had a 4.0 the rest of them had two
of them didn't have college education
they lived on less than they making the
invest over a long long period of time
using Chris Hogan's rules from retire
inspired and the stuff we talk about
here on the air and so in other words if
you do the stuff we talk about here on
the air you get out of that you live on
a plan you live on less than you make
and you attack this stuff then you know
you're going to you're going to see the
breakthrough and it's going to take you
10 to 15 years before you see it but
you're going to probably see a
million-dollar shift and most of you
listening right now
so don't believe the crap on the
television rich people aren't evil
they're people just like you they just
live it unless they make they save money
really who they are so quit believing
all this garbage is flying around and
start living a life based in reality
that's a millionaire theme our on the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or twenty
seven thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income a five hundred
thousand dollar income